[Music]
in hurry up news boo that they submitted
by David's pinky toe oh you actually
have nice feet I hate it
a college is apologizing after dragging
dancing graduates off the stage
why would you what a college who dragged
them off like cops or campus security
technically it's the University of
Florida that's a college right it's a
college when you say like I went to
college in America
yeah college and university is used the
same way but in the UK and Australia
College is actually high school yeah is
it really is this an American story or
Florida alright so then it will change
the way yeah it wouldn't be what he said
all right so this happen at the
University of Florida I'm gonna show you
guys the clip oh I love these clips man
this is awesome you've ever seen Clint I
just always wonder what happened don't
steal God's ideas for your show I'm not
I never watched any clips I just wonder
what happened commencement celebrations
cut short for these University of
Florida brands this shows black students
enjoying their moment dancing reportedly
being rushed off the stage for taking
too long at the University now facing
backlash accused of targeting only black
students at the ceremony he wasn't a
video to let the white students dance my
University's president apologizing at
another ceremony we inappropriately
physically rushed a number of students
across the stage and one of our
commencements and I want to personally
apologize for us doing that on behalf of
myself and also the University of
Florida well that's nice of him that was
a good apology yeah not too sincere
lunch I never really hear apologies like
that they always deny it or don't even
[ __ ] in or they make it so vain I know
what the rules were before headed that's
it that's hey you have four seconds to
walk across please don't do any dancing
stuff because it's like disruptive and
they did it anyways maybe oh that's
right because they do have rehearsal
they talked about
and there's a shits and a [ __ ]
student yep and it's the boring [ __ ]
ever I've seen a lot of people
celebrating and dancing on every
graduation those name is not a black kid
thing it's like everyone does that so
why I don't know it doesn't make sense
to me like why I seem like we're quite
non black people like our kids well the
white kids are gonna go after that it's
just too good yeah pressing the Nene for
hours and didn't work out and then the
video there's all these tweets here and
there's one tweet that says but Kevin
the Caucasian got a whole 45 seconds of
camera time somebody should have fell
out oh damn
so there are saying that there were
other students that were taking way
longer than view they were but that they
weren't blacks so there's like Asian
break dancers and they were cool with
that they should have put that in the
video then to show that that looks right
yeah yeah I want to see a [ __ ] little
Chinese girl bring out her fans with the
umbrella and they spit it around or that
guy that's always in his front yard yeah
cuz I'd be [ __ ] mad yeah I mean yeah
twenty kids already done this and then
they told him not to do it fifty times
and then they still like it let's see
the cool story apparently there were 21
students that were forced off the stage
all black that's what they're saying
that it was mainly black kid they should
have really thought about that then it
was very trying time for race they were
just like aggressively taking them away
- it wasn't even like just yet that guy
was [ __ ] over but maybe didn't
announce 220 times you just don't know
that's the thing if not though I mean
it's definitely kind of messed up they
cut out an ounce of 20 times they could
have already warned them during the
rehearsal like who knows because I know
right now like race is such a hot topic
that the news love the [ __ ] cover
this [ __ ] to divide people up yeah -
[ __ ] it's like unless we were there
at the event guess anything yeah but if
that guy was specifically targeting the
black is that's really [ __ ] up yeah
it's [ __ ] up
but I feel like these days if that's
happening people let the graduation
would have flipped out and lost their
[ __ ] yeah like you know what I'm saying
any everyone would have stopped yeah and
because I don't think people are as
racist as these these stories are set up
to make people seem to be yeah like if
so if we would have seemed like a white
guy like pushing black men or black
women off of a palpable place and it
seemed egregious or anybody but what is
that booed people wouldn't people who
lost their [ __ ] yeah yeah people lost
their [ __ ] I think it's the way that
they're framing it but also the kids
their experience something that they
felt targeted so they're tweeting that
out too right yeah it's like they were
saying that they just felt embarrassed
and and Plus like this is this thing
that they're trying to do is call it's
trolling I guess so they're doing like
they're strolling moves and that
everyone does it's like for forever
people have been doing this and so like
now all of a sudden these people just
started being really aggressive like
aggressively removing so like is it
tradition for every year during
graduation everybody does they're like
oh that's and then some of these people
were in like sororities or fraternities
and they were doing like their own oh
yeah they gotta do their home yeah yeah
call out their crew yeah yeah I want to
know the reason why they're so against
the celebration because it's a
graduation is just they should be a lot
so it's an awesome time like everyone's
like man you were moving to another you
worked a long time for it you should be
able to celebrate because you get your
[ __ ] few seconds right yeah they were
milking it and then they were like
taking their time tippy-toeing and
dancing and it was like all right man
that's been five minutes
yeah that's but [ __ ] it doesn't make it
the whole yeah just a little story it's
just weird yeah there are nearly ten
thousand students then you know what you
got one-and-a-half seconds right or do
it as a group you better get out there
yeah
the only graduation I'm going to is like
in the med school or some [ __ ] you know
and like that's because it's small yeah
I'm not going to my own graduation for
that big I mean they did the whole
school at once usually they break it up
into like major groups
what department is that budget on
education because mine was just the
business department yeah that was the
social studies that department dude
Eddie the Child Development good boy
yeah kind of look like that yeah well my
mom was one department and they look
like that though but if it's ten
thousand students graduating then they
they really have like 10 seconds or some
[ __ ]
mad although that's all ten thousand
that's way too many I don't think it's
ten thousand students I think it's ten
thousand attempt t yeah and the whole
arena probably everybody in that place
there's no way ten thousand students
graduated at once cuz if that was a case
I would just tell my kid I'm not going
near Lea 10,000 members spring 2018
graduating class yep that's that's the
whole class I wouldn't even show up and
tell like the letter of my kids last
name was about to be there cuz that's
gonna be three hours so just chaos or
three hours of jade that makes sense why
they're rushing so much because there's
10,000 students they got to get
everybody just handled it so stupid
that's why I'm saying it's [ __ ] dumb
why didn't they break it up and like
split up the groups they [ __ ] up it's
too late they're taking their time
everyone's dancing they should just be
like okay the [ __ ] rigid ass dude
that was like pulling people off you're
ruining though yes the announcer should
be like all right guys I'm so happy
everyone's enjoying it
we gotta have to speed it up a little
bit or else no one's gonna go home or
what they should have done was just like
18 black kids and then slap up a couple
Asian kids and then throw a couple like
yeah stage you know you can't say
anything that's true you slap all the
kids yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel like
after the president apologized because
there was a few students that were
interviewed for this specific is that a
different graduation that he was
apologized Oh ceremony I thought I was
just wearing those funny clothes at home
or something yeah just watching
television of the house and all those
necklaces and it's like Shakespearean
role yes like the three students that
I saw being pulled off of the stage so
they were being interviewed and so they
were saying that it was that apologies
not in a hole me personally I'm like
what do you want to do you know what
they should have another celebration for
all the people that got pulled out and
give every person three minutes of dance
time yeah they could dance them yeah
everyone just lines up and and they
could choose they could Choo's the song
that they want so it's like I and then
they could walk from the end like a
boxer yeah like a boxer is dope anything
they could have their crew to so then
when they're what like they could all
dance with their group and then they
could come up in the group supports them
and wrestle yeah they can wrestle yeah
I'll be pretty cool yeah cuz it's only
12 students right 21 21 you do that easy
three minutes each I think I think
that'll make it up that's a good idea
actually yeah or you graduated just move
on with your [ __ ] life yeah go get a
job dude it's like I only graduate one
thing I only get my bachelor's once and
you made the news that's awesome yeah
their time every day it's ruined for me
like I would just felt I didn't [ __ ]
walk I think if you think of your life
in single instances you don't have much
to look forward to anyways hmm my [ __ ]
is like it happens once that's great
we're all gonna die yeah I mean who the
[ __ ] cares yeah let me move on this
there's so much more great things out
there and there's a world that just
graduated in yeah you'd be okay yeah the
odds are you probably not gonna get that
good of a job anyway so [ __ ] have fun
90% of us are gonna have shitty jobs
yeah if people get mad it's like it's
like you missed my birthday [ __ ] you
got so much poor [ __ ] gentle relax dude
like it's okay I just saw that Regina no
don't no that's a different thing I
[ __ ] up on that one yeah don't lighten
up it uh these you go watch this
everyone tide you I didn't even invite
anyone to my graduation cuz I was like I
don't want to waste no-one's time that's
so nice yeah I just want my diploma ship
I was like as soon as I got my degree I
was like I'm ready to work I wanted I
need to get a job I got time for know
where my difference you don't you don't
know I know I got it I just don't want
it mines how much envelope that it came
in that big-ass [ __ ] yeah you hate
that
20 for that piece of paper I know they
don't even check you know that no they
don't you I've never checked if you make
a resume you could say you [ __ ] went
to Harvard they don't [ __ ] challenge
are over you into high school you're
welcome for the tips you get to lie
about everything I used to put my GPA
inside my resume no one gave a [ __ ] what
a nerd nobody gave a [ __ ]
my buddy made a fake when it said ha a
high school Harvard at the end of it
that's what it said for his high school
Perkin diploma and people were like
you're into high school Harvard like he
was an idiot you just thought it was
like the best high school yeah so
[ __ ] funny school har and he got a
job yeah um high school Harvard he still
has that on his wall at home high school
already now he's a manager yeah you know
what my cousin told me is he was
interning at this accounting firm and
then they were like yeah we don't if
someone has a 4.0 we throw that resume
out and he's like because in business
you need to have social skills and we
figure people with 4 point knows they're
just [ __ ] nerds damn and then they're
like we're looking for the 3.2 s to the
3.6 Wow yeah it's like you care but not
too much yeah it's like you're good
enough you do the work but then you've
got a life you got a couple of mistakes
yeah yeah you're gonna get in trouble
iff or three or four years at the
company you're gonna get in trouble a
little bit embezzle a little
[Music]